let's how about the end of the tour it's
it's this great and compelling story
about obviously this is this is a David
Foster Wallace has written the seminal
book of the 90s Infinite Jest and he's
getting a lot of attention but he's a
very reclusive character keeps to
himself very complicated and this is
about a writer and he's played by Jesse
Eisenberg a Rolling Stone writer who
comes to interview him and spend a
couple of days with him and it really is
very it's it's so well done in so
nuanced it's really great you give a
great performance Jesse Eisenberg is
great is Fanta and it really it like I
said it's it's funny it's it's sad all
at the same time thank you yeah it's
it's a really interesting movie and it's
a complicated thing where you know this
guy has accomplished everything he
wanted to accomplish he wrote this book
and I'm sure you've dealt with this
we've all dealt with this this moment
where things go as well as they can
possibly go and you realize you still
feel the same mmm like the thing that
was supposed to do it didn't do it it's
a very terrifying moment and meanwhile
rolling stone is sent this reporter to
kind of ask him what does it feel like
to be the writer of a generation and
he's scared because he feels terrible
yes yeah and they're swirling rumors
about addiction that Jesse Eisenberg's
character is really trying to uncover
Jesse Eisenberg's eating a lot of
pressure from Rolling Stone magazine
asked about a date or asking about this
and you can see what a gentle sweet
character you are if Esther was was in
in real life and it's very complicated
like you know yeah I mean I think it's a
guy who's to some extent getting to talk
to his younger self look back at himself
full of ambition but hasn't done the
thing yet and say hey be careful
it's different over here than you think
it's going to be be careful what you
wish for yeah that's right and meeting
your idols is a really tricky thing um I
thought you handled it well yeah you
nailed that joke haha great good night
I wasn't kidding uh